hello and welcome to the session on
implementation of time series with our
this is the second part of a two-part
series about time series data in the
first video we saw what exactly time
series data is all about and in this
video we are going to implement it in
our before we do that let's do a quick
recap of what we did in part 1 of this
video and we will then move into the
implementation so we talked about what
is time series we did an introduction to
time series in part 1 and we saw that
time series is a sequence of data that
is recorded at regular intervals to be
daily monthly weekly whatever and
needless to say the data is time
dependent and then we have some
historical data based on this historical
data we try to predict or forecast some
future values and we also saw that time
series data has these four components
there is a trend and there is
seasonality cyclicity and randomness or
irregularity and we also talked about
stationarity of time series data because
before we do any time series analysis we
need to make the data stationary and the
three components that are responsible
for stationarity are mean variance and
covariance this is how a stationary time
series data would love if we plot a time
series data and if we plot the mean of
time series data that would be constant
like this if it is stationary if it is
non stationary then it would be changing
and we also talked about how to find the
moving average the concept of moving
average how to calculate the moving
average and also in order to get a
smooth the whole thing we talked about
the centralized or center data center
moving average and this is how if we
plot and visualize this all the data
would look this blue color is the actual
data and then the green color
the centered moving average and the red
color is the red colored graph of the
line is there are the predicted values
so with that recap let's go ahead and
implement a time series forecast in our
so in this section what are we going to
do we are going to use a Rhema model
there are different models and
algorithms for performing time series
forecast so we will use our email which
is the most common one and you'll also
talk about what is autocorrelation like
partial autocorrelation and we will see
that in our studio as well and then we
will take you through a use case where
we will focus the a ticket sales for the
future and then we will end with the
model validation using the jump box text
okay so with that let's get started
first of all as I mentioned we will be
using the ARIMA model to do the forecast
of this time series data so let us try
to understand what is re model so ARIMA
is actually an acronym it stands for
auto regressive integrated moving
average so that is what is ARIMA model
and it is specified by three parameters
which is P T and Q P stands for auto
regressive so let me just mark this so
there are three components here auto
regressive integrated moving average
okay so these three parameters
correspond to those three components so
the P stands for auto regressive D for
integrated and Q for moving average so
let us see what exactly this is so these
three factors are P is the number of
auto regressive terms or AR we will see
that in a little bit and D is how many
levels of differences that we need to do
or differentiation we need to do and Q
is the number of lag forecast error so
we will see what exactly
each of these are so AR is the number of
auto regressive terms and which is
basically you know
by the P and then we have D which is for
the number of times it has to be
differentiated and then we have Q which
is for the moving average so what
exactly a are terms so in terms of the
regression model auto regressive
components refer to the prior values of
the current value what we mean by that
is here when we talk about time series
data focus on the fact that there is a
regression so what exactly happens in
regression we try to do something like
if it is simple linear regression we do
a some equation like y is equal to MX
plus C when there are actually there are
two variables one is the dependent
variable and then there is an
independent variable let me just
complete this equation as well MX plus C
so this is a normal regression curve or
a simple regression curve now here we
are talking about auto regression or our
auto regressive
so hot or aggressive as the name
suggests is regression of itself so
which means that here you have only one
variable which is your may be the cost
of the flights or whatever it is right
and the other variable is basically time
dependent and therefore the value at any
given time and that we will denote as YT
for example so there is no X here there
is only one variable and which is y and
we say YT which is basically the
predicted value at a time interval T for
example is dependent on the previous
value so for example there may be a one
and then YT minus one and then there
will be like plus a two and write plus
a2 and YT minus two and all right and
then plus a 3 into y t minus 3 all right
so basically here what we are saying is
there's only one variable here but there
is a regression component so we are
doing a regression on itself so that's
how the term auto regression comes into
play so only thing is that it is
dependent on the previous time value so
there is a lag let's say
is the first leg second leg Paraguay so
on so the current value which is YT is
dependent on the previous time lag
values so that is what is auto
regression component so this is what is
shown here for example in this case
instead of Y we aren't calling it as X
so that's the same and this is
represented by some equation of that saw
depending on how many legs we take so
that is the AR component and the term P
is basically determines how many lags we
are considering so that's B far now what
is d T is the degree of differencing so
here differencing is like two for the
non seasonal differences right so for
example if you take the values like this
which are given four five or six and so
on and so forth if you take the
differencing of one after another like
for example 5 minus 4 or 4 minus 5 the
next value with the previous value so 4
minus 5 so this is known as the first
order differencing so the result is
minus 1 similarly 6 minus 4 is 2 7 minus
6 is 1 so this is first order
differencing and here we call it as d is
equal to 1 okay and same way we can have
second order third order and so on then
the last one is Q q is the actually why
we call it moving average but in reality
it is actually the error of the model so
we also sometimes represent as et all
right so now
ARIMA model works some assumption that
the data is stationary which means that
the trend and seasonality of the data
has been removed that is correct ok so
this we have discussed in the first part
of what exactly is stationary data and
how do we remove the non stationary part
of it now in order to test whether the
data is stationary
there are two important components that
are considered one is the
autocorrelation function and the other
is the partial autocorrelation function
so this is referred to as a CF and PS EF
right so what is on the correlation and
what is the definition or the
correlation is basically the similarity
between values of same variable across
evasions as the name suggests now how do
we actually find the autocorrelation
function the value right so this is
basically done by plotting an
autocorrelation function also tells you
how correlated points are with each
other based on how many time steps they
are separated by and so on that is
basically the time lag that we are
talking about and it is also used to
determine how past and future data
points are related and the value of the
autocorrelation function can vary from
minus 1 to 1 so if we plot this is how
it would look or the correlation
function would look somewhat like this
and there is actually readily available
function in R so we will see that and
you can use that to plot your
autocorrelation function okay so that is
ACF and we will see that in our asks to
go in a little bit and similarly you
have partial autocorrelation function so
partial autocorrelation function is the
degree of association between two
variables while adjusting the effect of
one or more additional variables so this
again can be measured and it can also be
plotted and its value once again can go
from minus 1 to 1 and it gives the
partial correlation of time series with
its own lagged values so lag again we
have discussed in the previous couple of
slides this is how a PSE F plot would
look in our studio we will see that as
well and once we get into the our studio
and with that let's get into our studio
and take a look at our use case before
we go into the code let's just quickly
understand what exactly is the objective
of this use case so we are going to
predict some values or forecast some
values and we have the data of the
airline ticket sales of the previous
years and now we will try to find the
predictor or forecast the values for the
future year's rent so we basically
identify the time series components like
transition a leti and a random behavior
we will actually visualize this in our
studio and
we will actually forecast them - based
on the past values our history and
historical data so these are the steps
that we follow we will see in our studio
in a little bit just quickly let's go
through what are the steps we load the
data and it is a time series data and we
try to find out what class it belongs to
the data is actually 8 passengers data
that is already comes preloaded with our
studio so we will be using that and we
can take a look at the data and then
what is the starting point what is the
end point so these are all functions
that are readily available we'll be
using and then what is the frequency
that's basically the frequency is 12
which is in like yearly data right so
every month the data has been collected
so for each year it is 12 and then we
can check for many missing values if
there are any and then we can take a
look at summary of the data this is what
we do in exploratory data analysis and
then we can plot the data visualize the
data how it is looking and we will see
how the data has some trend seasonality
and so on and so forth all right then we
can take a look at the cycle of the data
using the cycle function and we can see
that it is every month that's the cycle
and of every 12 months
it is a new cycle begins so the each
month of the year as the data is
available then we can do box plots to
see for each month how the data is
varying over the various ten or twelve
years that we will be looking at this
data and from exploratory data analysis
we can identify that there is a trend
there is a seasonality component and how
the seasonality component varies also we
can see from the box plots and we can
decompose the data we can use the
decomposed function rather to see the
various components like the seasonality
trend the irregularity part bucket so we
will see all of this in our studio this
is how they will look this is the once
you decompose and this is how you will
actually you can visualize the data this
is the actual data and this is the trend
as you can see it's going upwards this
is the seasonal component
and this is your random or a regularity
right so we call it irregularity or we
can also call it right now as you can
see here yes so the data must have a
constant variance and mean which means
that it is stationary before we start
any analysis time series analysis and we
thought so basically yeah if it is
station and only then it is easy to
model the data perform time series
analysis so we can then go ahead and fit
the model as we discussed earlier will
be using re more model there are some
techniques to find out what should be
the parameter so we will see that when
we go into our studio so the auto ARIMA
function basically tells us what should
be the parameters right so these
parameters are the PD and Q that we
talked about that so what is being shown
here
so if we use Auto Rema it will basically
take all possible values of this PDQ
these parameters and it will find out
what is the best value and then it will
recommend so that is the advantage of
using Auto ARIMA all right so like in
this case it will tell us if we use this
parameter trace we set the parameter
trace is equal to true then it will
basically tell us what is the value of
this AIC which has to be minimum so then
we lower the value the better so for
each of these combinations of PT and Q
it will give us the values here and then
it will recommend to us which is the
best model okay because the Chavan has
the lowest value of this AIC it will
recommend that as your best PDQ values
so once we have that we can see that we
will basically we can potentially get a
model or the equation model is nothing
but the equation and based on the
parameters that we get and we can do
some Diagnostics we can do some plotting
to see how then there is a slot for the
residuals so which shows the
stationarity and then we can also take a
look at the ACF and P ACF we can plot
the ACF and P ACF
then we can do some forecasting for the
future year so in this case we have up
to 1960 and then we can see how we can
forecast for the next ten years which is
1970 up to 1970 and once we have done
this can we validate this model yes
definitely we can validate this model
and to validate the findings we use jump
box test and this is how you just call
box dot test and then you pass these
parameters and you will get the values
that will be returned which will tell us
whether this how accurate this model is
all accurate deflections are so the
values of P are quite insignificant in
this case we will see that and that also
indicates that our model is free of
autocorrelation and that will basically
be it so let's go back and into our our
studio and go through these steps in
real time so we have to import this
library forecast package is not
installed you have to go here and
install the forecast package ok so
that's the easy way to install rather
than to click on this install I will not
do it now because I have already
installed so the first time that's only
one time then after that you just have
to load it into memory and then keep
going so we will load this data called
air passengers so by calling this data
method and if you see the data a
passengers is loaded here and if we
check for the class it is a time series
data ts data so we can check for the
dates you can also view the data in a
little bit and the start date is 1949
and January and our end date is 1960
December and the frequency is 12 which
is like collected monthly so that is the
frequency which is 12 here and then we
check if there are any missing values
there are no missing values and then we
take a look at the summary of the data
this is all exploratory data analysis
and then if you just display the data
this is how it looks
and then we need to decompose this data
so we will kind of store this in an
object es data and then use that to
decompose and store the new values let
me just clear this for now and if we
decompose basically as we have seen in
the slides decomposing is breaking it
into the transition ality and irregular
or random components then you can go
ahead and plot it so when you plot it
you can see here let me zoom this this
is original plot or observed value as it
is known as then we have decomposed the
three parts which is basically the trend
as you can see there is an upward trend
then the seasonal component so this is
some regularly occurring pattern and
then there is a random value which is
basically you cannot really give any
equation or function or anything like
that so that's what this plotting has
done and then you can actually plot them
individually as well so these are the
individual plots for the trend or the
seasonal component and the random
component alright so now let's take a
look at the original data and see how
the trend is in a way so if we do this
linear regression line it will show that
there it is going upwards and we can
also take a look at the cycle that are
there which is nothing but we have
frequency of 12 right so those cycles
will display that it is January February
to December and then back to January
February and so on and so forth and if
we do box plots for the monthly data you
will see that for each of the months
right and over the ten years that the
data that we have we will see that there
is a certain pattern right this is also
you know way to find the seasonality
component so while January February
sales are relatively low around July
August the sales pickup so especially in
July I think the sales are the highest
and this seems to be happening pretty
much every year right so this is every
year in July there seems to be a peak in
the sales and then it goes down and
slightly higher in December and so on so
that is again part of our exploratory
data analysis and once again let's just
plot the data now
as I said in order to fit into an edema
model we need the values of P D and Q
now one way of doing it is there are
multiple ways actually of doing it the
earlier method of doing it was you draw
the autocorrelation function plot and
then partial autocorrelation function
plot and then observe that and where
does this change and then identify what
should be the values of P and Q and so
on now our really has a very beautiful
method which we can use to avoid all
that manual process that we used to do
earlier so what are will do is there is
a method called Auto ARIMA and if we
just call this Auto ARIMA method and it
will basically go and test the ARIMA
model for all possible values of this
parameter speedy Q and then it will
suggest to you what should be the best
model and it will return that best model
with the right values of P D and Q so
you
we as data scientists don't have to do
any manual you know trial and error kind
of stuff okay so we got the model now
and this is the model which it has P D Q
values are 2 1 1 the PDQ and this is the
seasonal part of it so we can ignore it
for now and so if we want to actually
understand how this has returned these
values 2 1 1 as the best one there is
another functionality or feature where
we can use this trace function or trace
parameter so if you pass to Auto ARIMA
the trace parameter what it will do is
it will show you how it is doing this
calculation what is the value of the AIC
basically a C is what defines the
accuracy of the model the lower the
pattern okay so for each combination of
PDQ it will show us the value of AIC so
let's run it before instead of me
talking so much let's run this if we run
Auto re mahmud trace you see here there
is a red mark here that means it is
performing it is executing this and here
we see the display right so it starts
with certain values of PDQ and then it
finds that value is too high so
starts with a game with some 0 1 0 and
so on and so forth and ultimately it
Elsa's okay this is our best model you
see yeah so it says this is our best
model 2 1 1 let's go back and see did we
get the same one
yes we got the same one when we ran
without trace as well right now why is 2
1 1 let us see where is 2 1 1 here is
our 2 1 1 and if you compare the values
you see that 1 0 1 7 is pretty much the
lowest value and therefore it is saying
this is our best model all other values
are higher so that's how you kind of get
your model and then now that you have
your model what you have to do you need
to predict the values right so before
that let us just do some tests of these
values so for that you install t-series
again if you are doing it for the first
time you would rather use this package
and install and say TC is and install it
and then you just use this library
function to load it into your memory all
right so now that we got our model using
Auto ARIMA let us go ahead and forecast
and also test the model and also plot
the ACF and PSC f remember we talked
about this but we did not really use it
we don't have to use that but at least
we will visualize it and for some of
those stuff we may need this t-series
palabra t so if you are doing this for
the first time you may have to install
it and my recommendation is don't use it
in the code you go here and install t
series and i will not do it now because
i have already installed it but this is
a preferred method and once you install
it you just load it using this libraries
function and then you can plot your
residuals and this is all the residuals
look and you can plot your ACF and T SEM
ok so this is all your PACA flux and
this is how your ACF looks for now there
is really nothing else we need to do
with ACF and P ACF is just to visualize
how that how it looks but as I mentioned
we were actually using these
visualizations or these graphs to
identify the values of P D and Q and how
that was done it's out of scope of this
video so we will leave it at that and
then we will forecast for the next 10
years how do we focus that so we call
forecast and we pass the model and we
pass what is the level of accuracy that
you need which is 95 percent and for how
many periods right so basically we want
for 10 years which is like 10 into 12
time periods
so that's what we are doing here and now
we can plot the forecast values so you
see this is the original value up to I
think 62 and then it goes up to 72 this
blue color is the predicted value let's
go and zoom it up so that we can see it
better so from here onwards your
forecasting and you can see that it
looks like our model has kind of learnt
the pattern and this pattern looks very
similar to what we see in the actual
data now how do we test our model so we
can do what is known as a box test and
we pass our model here residuals
basically with different lags and from
those values here the p-values here we
find that they're reasonably low
p-values which means our model is fairly
accurate okay great so I hope this was
helpful and with this we come to the end
of this video
all right so with that we pretty much
come to the end of this video and quick
summary we talked about what is the Rema
model what are they R and D which is for
the degree of difference and moving
average so the PDQ values we talked
about we briefly touched upon
autocorrelation function and partial
autocorrelation function and we saw that
in our as well we plotted and soit in
our we saw how to implement this in our
studio and as a part of that we did some
exploratory data analysis and then we
did the time series decomposition and
then
finally we did the forecast and then we
kind of validated the model as well with
that we come to the end of this video I
hope you enjoyed this thank you very
much once again for joining and if you
have any comments or questions please
put it at the bottom of the video and
differently with some contact
information so that we can get back to
you and you have a great day thank you
once again bye bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turner up and get certified click
here